and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review star trek
into darkness
oh my god these are the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
live long it spoilers I can never get
that hand to do it here's this guy
called james t kirk and he's in trouble
because he met a bunch of paper mache
man know that there's an enterprise
around and Starfleet is like you've gone
too far Kirk I've taken you to price
away from you oh wow gee this is the
first time the enterprise has ever been
taken away from me we're not giving it
back oh yeah let me just wave goodbye to
a goodbye enterprise I'll never see you
again
I really mean it you're never ever ever
gonna seen that campus chair again okay
if you say so
so who's the captain now I am can I
serve under you Chur oh no it's just aa
MALDEF watch fit Starfleet anybody above
me is the new red shirt so a person we
all know his con comes in and shoots a
lot of the higher-ups and the Admiral is
like Kirk we need you to disobey orders
by doing what Starfleet says I have no
idea with it he wants you to illegally
but quietly take out this guy but how
are you gonna explain that he's dead
he's in Klingon territory and thankfully
we're all incredibly racist of them
right now we yes when people hate
something they're more likely to believe
stupid lies about it we'll just say they
ate him or something ready
but Scotty's like gods they above all
these incredibly dangerous torpedoes on
that's okay
well heading over to check out doing a
despicable me in presentation will he
say whistles he win I'm good boom so I
had to get the best people possible for
this mission I could kill them all in
stark war so let's end in a feeding
Spock enough room come on you were gonna
die earlier you didn't say you loved me
I was too busy pissing my pants if you
thought you were gonna do me again would
you say you love me is it your question
well I'm gonna kill you if you answer
wrong take this yet
my god my god we were saying focus not
reenacting Everybody Loves Raymond
epitome so all these Klingon shift force
them down to the ground because they're
incredibly outnumbered but then one guy
comes along destroys one ship and
somehow the others miraculously
disappeared I guess the Klingons were
like look out I know it sounds like scar
from The Lion King
ah don't enterprises like who are you
I'm that guy who everybody knows his car
but who are you really calm oh yeah so
he surrenders to the USS Enterprise
which carries if the villain of an
action movie surrenders halfway through
killing the bacala's life I'm going to
reenact silence of the last by being
assigned a cage and getting inside your
mind hey aren't you supposed to not be
British and have a plastic chest as her
some people in the top Ito's I do not
spec you deceive it but sure enough
there are frozen people inside the
torpedoes encourages like why are the
frozen people inside the torpedo sail
superhumans
so super they get captured by ice how
the whole my British accent oh but the
Admiral shows up and it's like hey you
fairly intimidating British guys hand
them over
nope he deserves to stand trial well
then I'll just show you and you're
screwed
not likely before I have your daughter
hi transporter beam er over hi okay now
we're screwed
so they had to think of a plan really
fast and curtains like time we have to
join forces a grade I'm sure we're gonna
turn out to be the best of friends yes
so they reenact that scene from Star
Trek nemesis you know the one that
everybody laughed at no not that one no
not that one no not that one yeah that
one where they jump from one ship to the
other exactly logically explain it ish
we'll get even with that by showing them
our cannonball impression what's our
cannonball
so curtain time get to the bridge of the
Admiral guy a tom is like admiral was
about to be puff like a pimple says
what's what and can tell spa time dover
my frozen crew i will heal and Nimoy
destroy your captain first hand over the
captain very well now send me incredibly
explosive torpedoes to me this was a
stupid idea by surprise is all broken up
and flying towards Earth which is weird
Earth never saw this whole battle thing
going on hey daddy look falling debris
Kirk is the only one to get the ship
back online by sacrificing his life and
courage like ship out of danger and
Spock is like oh my god your irony
levels are through the roof do not
grieve Spock line from Star Trek to live
from static to line from Star Trek to
line from Star Trek to a little bit of
new material a little bit of new
material unbelievably lame retread
unbelievably lame retread incredibly not
clever slap in the face to the fans he
coulda peanut could ever slap in the
face to the fans Oh free awkward
similarities so Spock is chasing after
Kahn on earth and comments like you
can't defeat me I am a superhuman
it's bhaktas like I'm an angry Vulcan
who eventually punch you over and over
even though we establish
where that does nothing but then a rule
pops up and is like and I will stun you
with this gun even though it took much
out before will take me like 20 this
time you know what I'm tired and those
both sound really intimidating but that
simply isn't enough running time to do
anything impressive with me though I'm
just gonna lie down and go to freeze but
dr. McCoy is like with Khan's blood I
brought this when I could head back to
life but maybe the same can be done for
Kirk but isn't he did if we freeze him
he'll be only half dead so Kirk comes
back to his life thank God we showed a
mini to one of the greatest Star Trek
villains of all time by easily defeating
him and just throwing him in an ice tray
but what have we learned about morality
and death I don't know Freddie
so the movie was really good except when
it just put in Star Trek 2 again me
remembering suburban nights where they
killed Matty and they kind of did it for
laughs imagine they're trying to be done
for real to pull the door nobody's gone
before how about the cowardly rich red
when we don't want to try and even know
I swear you can call the next film Star
Trek wrath of the message boards the
geeks are going to kill you JJ Abrams
but still the rest of the movie was a
lot of fun Phil it could use more
lightsabers but bottom line I enjoy
going into darkness even though I have
no idea what the darkness was in this
movie maybe I could tell better they
turned down the lens failures this is
Jesse Reid boom sing change you got
change ha ha come on up a guy oh we love
it come on Jay come on get Khan in the
next movie
Star Trek the wrath of I swear we'll do
something with a design Khan
you